comenzamos con la final de la copa
libertadores así es valentina que tal no
vamos a recordar esta final como la más
emocionante en la historia de la copa
libertadores el palmeiras se consagró
campeón ante el santos con un gol de
brno lópez en los últimos minutos del
descuento fue un partido con pocas
ocasiones y en general con poco
espectáculo ante un estadio maracaná con
un aforo del 10 por ciento el punto de
giro llegó con la expulsión de kucka el
técnico de santos ya en el tiempo
añadido fue justo tras la renovación del
juego que bruno lópez remató de manera
perfecta a un centro y puso el 1 a 0
final es la segunda copa libertadores
para el verdao y así se celebró en las
calles de sao paulo
[Aplausos]
un poco de distanciamiento social en la
celebración ellos el palmeiras no eran
los favoritos después de la sufrida
victoria ante river plate en semifinales
además santos he demostrado un mejor
rendimiento en todo el torneo pero hoy
el palmeiras el triunfo en este duelo de
poca ofensiva enhorabuena para ellos
enhorabuena para su técnico abel que es
el tercer técnico el europeo que se
consagra campeón de la copa libertadores